intoxicados con gases desconocidos así
están más de 100 personas de quintero y
puchuncaví lugar conocido como 'el
chernóbil chileno un problema que se ha
repetido durante varios años no podemos
seguir teniendo
sin controlar una empresa empresas que
producen tóxicos sin tener una normativa
en el país de qué estamos hablando si
esto pasa solamente en quintero
pero que algunos no solamente están en
quinteros ya tenemos cinco son el
sacrificio donde él
el gobierno y el estado no se ha hecho
responsable en 2018 unas 600 personas
acudieron a centros médicos con un
cuadro clínico atípico de vómitos de
sangre dolores de cabeza mareos
parálisis de las extremidades sumado
extremas ronchas en la piel que
sufrieron en particular niños
tuve mi hija con suero su diagnóstico
como te lo acabo de mostrar
intoxicación por gas el desconocido y
volvemos al mismo cuento del 2018 y
volvemos el mismo cuento no tanto del
2018 sino del 2014 y de hace años atrás
esto es una seguidilla de episodios este
lunes tras detectar una concentración de
dióxido de azufre 5 veces superior a la
permitida las autoridades declararon la
emergencia ambiental suspendieron las
clases y prohibieron la actividad física
en este foco de contaminación hay 4
termoeléctricas a carbón y refinerías de
crudo además está codelco empresa
estatal chilena de cobre responsable del
8 por ciento de la oferta mundial la
mayoría de la población trabaja en las
industrias contaminantes por lo que no
quieren el cierre definitivo de las
fábricas sino exigen del gobierno un
mejor hospital detenerlo en los
proyectos o trasladar a otros lugares la
fundición de codelco